I think the turning point for me in
terms of making a career choice when I
was 16 I had the fantastic opportunity
to go and work in a local hospital and
work with patients there was on the
heart-transplant wart and it was amazing
just to work with patients and get a
real feel for what it was like to be
around patients who who went well and i
found that such a rewarding experience
it was not unity for me to feel like I
was doing something rewarding on a daily
basis and it's something that I really
enjoyed so I say it definitely at 16 I
thought to have a real sense of what I
wants to do and having a an idea of
wanted to go into the health care
profession and then after that i did my
a levels in chemistry and biology and
then chose to do a career in pharmacy
and I think I've totally lands on my
feet coming to research